[Musique]
le Conseil constitutionnel proclame élu
président de la République quand le
Conseil consuel a été créé il prenait 5
décisions par an donner de la substance
à ses droits constitutionnels
aujourd'hui le Conseil constitutionnel
prend sans décision par an ça donne
toute sa place à l'état de droit le
Conseil constitutionnel mode d'emploi
le Conseil constitutionnel c'est quoi
épisode 1
[Musique]
le Conseil constitutionnel est une
institution française créée par la
Constitution de la Cinquième République
le conseil est logé dans une aile du
Palais Royal à Paris entre le ministère
de la culture et la Comédie-Française et
deux fois par semaine 9 sages se
réunissent pour juger de la
constitutionnalité des lois dont ils
sont saisis il forme alors le collège
des membres du Conseil 9 sages nommé
pour neuf ans par le Président de la
République celui du Sénat et celui de
l'Assemblée nationale il se renouvelle
tous les trois ans par tiers et c'est un
rituel qui remonte à 1958 à l'époque la
Quatrième République créée pour
reconstruire le pays après la deuxième
guerre mondiale est un régime
parlementaire à bout de souffle ce sont
les alliances entre les parties qui
forment les gouvernements ces derniers
se renversés au gré des combinaisons
partisanes c'est la Charlie incapable de
gérer les crises notamment les guerres
d'Indochine et d'Algérie le général de
Gaulle est alors appelé à la rescousse
et lance une réforme des institutions
qui leur a naissance à la Cinquième
République
un régime parlementaire présidentiel qui
se dotent d'un Conseil constitutionnel
personne n'imaginait en 1958 que le
Conseil constitutionnel serait ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui juge de la
constitutionnalité des lois
il avait d'abord été conçu comme le
gardien de la répartition des
compétences entre le Parlement et le
gouvernement pour être sûr que les
parties ne reprennent pas le pouvoir
qu'ils avaient sous la 4e République
d'où un rôle important du conseil qui
consistait à vérifier que le Parlement
ne reprenne pas plus de pouvoir que la
Constitution ne lui en accordait
justement parce qu'on pensait qu'il ne
serait pas très occupé par cette mission
on lui en avait confié d'autres par
exemple le fait de veiller à la
régularité du référendum de l'élection
présidentielle le fait d'être le juge
des élections législatives et
sénatoriales donc finalement sa
compétence était plus un patchwork que
qu'autre chose en 1958 9 sages gardiens
de l'équilibre des pouvoirs chargé de
faire respecter la Constitution l'idée
était il y avait une majorité gaullistes
au Parlement à l'Assemblée en mais si la
majorité gaulliste votait quelque chose
qui n'était pas tout à fait conforme à
ce que souhaitait l'exécutif à ce moment
là il fallait que le Conseil consuel
puisse censurer le texte aujourd'hui les
compétences du Conseil ont beaucoup
évolué il est devenu un véritable juge
de la constitutionnalité des lois en
exerçant soit un contrôle a priori soit
un contrôle à posteriori ce qui lui a
permis de s'émanciper du pouvoir
exécutif depuis 1958 il a rendu plus de
6000 décisions et les délibérés dont
elles sont issues sont secrets mais
pourquoi secret pourquoi ces secrets
parce que c'est considéré je pense que
c'est à raison comme une protection de
notre indépendance
la pression on ne peut pas faire
pression sur nous on ne sait pas comment
Monsieur X Madame Y s'est prononcé il
est très important que nous soyons
indépendants de tous les pouvoirs
[Musique]